zone europe / sensations
bonsoir et bienvenue dans un europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de strasbourg est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputée michèle rivasi sera notre
invité nous évoquerons avec l
utilisation des pesticides et ses
dangers pour la santé et l'environnement
la pma procréation médicalement assistée
est autorisé pour toutes les femmes en
france mais ailleurs en europe la
législation varie nous verrons comment
ça se passe chez nos voisins mais tout
de suite ce jour là le 25 mars 1957 deux
traités historiques sont signés à rome
qui fonde les bases de la construction
européenne plus de détails avec salomé
l'imri europe direct normandie evreux et
maison de l'europe de leur sceau
d'europe ce jour là
à la sortie de la seconde guerre
mondiale les 6 pays à l'origine de
l'intégration européenne france
l'allemagne l'italie la belgique le
luxembourg et les pays bas font un pas
de plus dans la construction entre les
pays en se réunissant à rome deux
traités sont signés en 1957 le premier
créé la communauté économique européenne
cee et le second la communauté
européenne de l'énergie atomique euratom
les deux entre en vigueur le 14 janvier
1958 les traités de rome font suite au
traité de la ceca de 1951 qui met en
commun les productions de charbon et
d'acier il relance l'intégration
européenne qui a subi un revers avec
l'échec de la création de la communauté
européenne de la défense en 1954 la
création d'euratom cee a est né d'une
idée française son but était de
permettre l'autosuffisance énergétique
des continents à travers la maîtrise du
nucléaire une assurance de paix pour le
continent européen à la suite de la
crise de suez en 1956 et le blocus du
golfe d'aqaba une pénurie de carburant
fait prendre conscience de l'importance
de l'indépendance énergétique euratom se
donne pour mission de permettre aux
états de développer une puissante
industrie nucléaire de moderniser les
techniques en associant d'autres pays et
organisations internationales la
communauté européenne de l'énergie
atomique devait aussi permettre de
lancer une coopération entre les six
états fondateurs et les etats unis en
matière de technologie nucléaire
aujourd'hui euratom est toujours active
elle gère le marché commun des matières
nucléaires et finance un centre commun
de recherche on peut cependant noter les
difficultés rencontrées par cette
coopération par le passé certains états
n'ont pas intégré la création de leurs
centrales nucléaires dans une logique
communautaire et ont souhaité utiliser
les fonds d'euratom pour développer des
programmes de recherche nationaux la
disparition de ratoma été envisagée en
1970 cependant cette organisation
perdure ces travaux actuels portent sur
la protection de l'environnement et la
santé des travailleurs face au rayon
deuxième traité de rome créée lui la
communauté économique européenne cee une
étape pour garantir une prospérité et la
croissance en europe pour la première
fois un marché commun permet la
libéralisation du commerce entre les six
pays les règles du marché en matière de
concurrence de fiscalité est d accord
sur les tarifs douaniers assure son bon
fonctionnement
il faudra dix ans pour que les droits de
douane entre les pays soient
complètement abolie et le tarif douanier
commun établi mais les effets sont
immédiats entre 1958 et 1972 les
échanges dans la zone sont multipliées
par 9 le traité invite également les
états membres à se coordonner en
plusieurs domaines politique économique
celle-ci est déterminé à l'échelle
européenne cela oblige les pays membres
de la cae d'avoir une voix commune dans
les négociations commerciales
internationales politiques sociales le
traité de rome créé le fonds social
européen qui soutient la formation des
travailleurs il incite également les et
à harmoniser leurs initiatives dans le
domaine du social
l'article 2 du traité de rome résume
bien le but recherché la communauté a
pour mission par l'établissement d'un
marché commun et par le rapprochement
progressif des politiques économiques
des états membres de promouvoir un
développement harmonieux des activités
économiques dans l'ensemble de la
communauté une expansion continue et
équilibrée une stabilité accrue un
relèvement accélérée du niveau de vie et
des relations plus étroites entre les
états qu'elle régule dans le même temps
en 1957 une ré fonte du système des
institutions mènent à la création d'un
exécutif indépendant des états la
commission européenne qui a le droit
d'initiative exclusif les compétences
décisionnelles sont elles attribuent au
conseil des ministres est l'ancêtre du
parlement européen l'assemblée
européenne n'a qu'un contrôle politique
sur la commission
le traité de rome a été ensuite complété
par l'acte unique en 1989 et le traité
de lisbonne en 2009 il a ouvert la voie
à la création de politiques communes
d'envergure notamment la pac politique
agricole commune les traités de rome
font donc partie des textes fondateurs
de l'union européenne ils affirment les
principes de solidarité entre les pays
d'égalité entre les pays égalité hommes
femmes et la volonté de maintenir la
paix toujours autant d'actualité en
europe
zone europe l'invité tic
je reçois aujourd'hui michèle rivasi
bonjour bush ou alors vous êtes
eurodéputés membres du groupe des verts
alliance libre européenne membre
suppléant de la commission de
l'environnement de là santé publique et
de la sécurité alimentaire alimentaires
alors en mars dernier pour faire face
aux conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
la commission européenne a présenté
différentes mesures pour augmenter la
production agricole et garantir la
sécurité alimentaire dans l'union
européenne mais également au niveau
mondial alors en avant d'en venir à
l'utilisation des pesticides déjà est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner votre
sentiment sur ce premier volet bah
écoutez j'ai pas compris la position de
la commission est notamment aussi les
états membres parce qu'en fait ils
profitent de la guerre en ukraine
par les russes pour dire regardez il ya
l'augmentation prix il ya des pays qui
vont
avoir des difficultés pour
s'approvisionner donc ce qu'a fait
la politique agricole commune européenne
par le green deal eh ben on va faire
sauter tout ce qui touche à
l'environnement parce qu'il y avait
quatre pour cent des terres qui devait
être mis en jachère
et dans ces terres là on devait pas
utiliser des pesticides et les syndicats
majoritaires au niveau des agriculteurs
en profiter de ça pour dire il faut
augmenter la production mais c'est pas
un problème de production c'est un
problème que il ya eu une augmentation
de prix d'ailleurs qui était avant la
guerre en ukraine parce qu'il ya des
problèmes de spéculation parce que
il ya un problème aussi de distribution
et que la guerre n'a fait qu'aggraver le
problème mais
le sujet c'est pas qu'il ya un manque de
production il faut la distribuer et
surtout il faut que les prix
n'augmentent pas pour que des pays comme
les pays du maghreb comme par exemple
l'egypte mais le sénégal le yémen etc
qui utilisent énormément de céréales
puisse
faire en sorte à ce que ça soit
abordable vous portez régulièrement le
poids des lobbys au parlement européen
avoue penser que les lobbys profite de
la guerre en ukraine au bras c'est
vraiment c'est l'agrobusiness qui
profitent de la guerre en ukraine pour
d'une part spéculer et puis d'autre part
casser le fait qu'on avait obtenu
quelques mesures environnementales pour
diminuer la quantité de pesticides pour
développer par exemple l'agriculture
biologique puisque dans le plan il y
avait de la ferme à la fourchette il y
avait au moins 25% de terre en bio il y
avait moins d'utilisation des intrants
et on voit bien les intrants c'est quoi
ces les engrais or on est très dépendant
justement des engrais qui viennent à la
fois du bélarus mais aussi de russie par
rapport au gaz et donc il profite de ça
pour dire il faut faire sauter ces
jachères et il faut augmenter la
production certains eurodéputés salue
l'action des lobbys au parlement
européen qu'est ce que vous avez à leur
dire mais quel lobby de quel lobby on
parle si on parle des lobbys qui sont
pour augmenter une agriculture intensive
justement qui nous rendent dépendant des
pays comme la russie par son gaz ou
d'autres pays je vois pas quel est
l'intérêt nous on a toujours défendu une
agriculture si vous voulez qu'il soit la
plus résiliente possible c'est-à-dire
qu'ils s'adaptent de plus en plus
vis-à-vis du réchauffement climatique et
pour ça il faut une agriculture très
diverses il faut développer les
écosystèmes il faut développer là
seulement il faut développer la rotation
des cultures voyez l'agroécologie c'est
quand même une agriculture justement qui
n'utilise pas de pesticides qui
n'utilise pas d'eau gm qui est qui est
une agriculture si vous voulez qui est
très équilibré et qui joue sur la
diversité l'agriculture intensive quand
je vous parle des lobbys ils sont
derrière qu'est ce qu'ils veulent ils
veulent qu'on achète encore le plus un
cran ils veulent qu'on achète encore
plus de pesticides ils veulent des
semences justement que c'est les gros
ce mancier qui vous vendent des semences
c'est ça qui les interdictions de
réutiliser ses propres graines pour
replanter dans les années suivantes par
exemple parce que si vous achetez ces
graines là vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de les replanter l'adie
suivante alors vous demande vous
réclamez un vous le disiez la fin des
pesticides à vous souligner le fait que
notamment l'exposition aux pesticides
c'est une menace pour l'environnement
mais également pour les droits humains
alors pour l'environnement on le voit
bien mais est ce que vous pourriez nous
expliquer en coinçant en quoi cela
concerne le droit humain eh bien je vais
vous prendre un exemple vous savez que
moi j'ai un combat depuis des années sur
ya
une centaine de pesticides alternée en
europe mais ils sont pas interdits de
fabrication et d'exportation alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe le lobby
justement des pesticides les lobbys dg
de la chimie et bien puisque c'est
interdit en europe ils vont l'exporter
en amérique du sud maromme le brésil
c'est un des pays qui utilisent le plus
de pesticides interdits ou en afrique
sauf que les gens ils n'ont pas la
connaissance et non pas la protection
pour l'utilisation de ces pesticides et
même par exemple on le sait au brésil il
utilise les pesticides pour chasser les
peuples autochtones et des droits
humains c'est à dire que il ya une telle
pression qui se fait à l'heure actuelle
pour alimenter par exemple les élevages
industriels de tourteaux de soja qui
viennent de ces pays là qu'ils sont en
train de détruire la forêt amazonienne
est très souvent monde a vu carrément
des hélicos qui balançaient les
pesticides sur les villages de ces
peuples autochtones donc oui ça joue sur
l'environnement parce que ça entraîne
des maladies s'entraîne des mots mais
aussi sa chasse les ces populations qui
tombe malade et qui sont obligés de
partir et ils ont de moins en moins de
l'espace vital d'ailleurs maintenant
pour faire en sorte à ce qu'ils puissent
vivre ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure quand je vous disais que les
lobbys joue un rôle incroyable de
désinformation par rapport à cette crise
en ukraine il est où le problème on a vu
je vous ai dit il n'y a pas de problèmes
de production mais surtout ce qu'il faut
bien savoir c'est que les élevages
industriels utilisent la plupart des
céréales qui viennent d'ukraine et de
russie pour l'élevage intensif et nous
on dit l'élevage intensif quand on parle
par exemple des bovins eh bien il faut
qu'ils reviennent au niveau de la terre
c'est quoi ces élevages ont très peu de
temps on augmente le voyez la proportion
de la viande et second pour d'ailleurs
pour l'exporter n'ont même pas pour
l'utiliser et ça nous utilisent voyez
ces terres là et puis la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de terre qui
sont utilisés pour l'agro carburant que
ça soit le bio de diesel ou le
bioéthanol il vaut mieux utiliser ses
hectares là pour produire vous voyez des
aliments et non pas du bio est un homme
du bio est-il donc si on veut augmenter
la production même si on rentre dans
leur logique et bien diminué ces
agrocarburants pour faire vraiment de
l'alimentation pour les humains vous
pensez que l'europe sur ce sujet les
hypocrites je pense qu'elle est
hypocrite parce que elle nous tient des
discours très bien moi de la ferme à la
fourchette je trouve ça super
quand elle parlait aussi de ça sera
quand même une législation sur le zéro
pesticide le zéro substances toxiques
donc vous voyez éliminer les
cancérogènes mutagènes perturbateurs
endocriniens et puis quand la loi sur la
santé et l'impact sur la santé bien sûr
et quand on voit la réalité bon il ya un
souci il ya une crise de suite c'est les
mesures environnementales et sanitaires
quand qu'on balance vous voyez bien que
ça tient pas la route pensait que la
transition écologique telle qu'on la
souhaite avec l'objectif en 2050 et
nabeul avec les sanctions et parents qui
sont conjointes actuellement envers la
russie et ce qui se passe en ukraine
avait de toute façon bien sûr que les
tonnages et qu'elle est souhaitable et
puis on n'a pas bien de choix parce que
si on veut sortir des intrants si on
veut s'en sortir des engrais chimiques
il va falloir développer l'agro écologie
agroforesterie voyez c'est ce type de
culture où il ya un très bon rendement
d'ailleurs mais c'est vrai que hausser
un peu l'abandon des monocultures c'est
l'abandon de l'agro tout ce qui est à
gros carburant etc et puis c'est revenir
à plaindre petites exploitations vous
voyez où c'est beaucoup moins
digitalisées puisque oui l'europe elle
dit il faut digitalisées numérisés et
c'est comme si c'était la panacée mais
il faut revenir aux bases et je pense
que si on veut sortir de la crise si on
veut sortir aussi des plats
problématique du dérèglement climatique
il faut qu'on soit sur les peu de plus
petites exploitations que on ait une
diversité de semences quand on applique
si vous voulez la pluralité des cultures
pour augmenter les écosystèmes et c'est
comme ça qu'on peut se passer des
pesticides
voyez sa demande je vous dis une
rotation des cultures et sa demande il
peut y avoir des cultures par exemple
qui enrichissent la terre en nitrates
alors qu'à l'heure actuelle le modèle de
l'agriculture intensive et d'ailleurs le
rapport du giec lumens sortir le 10 il
ya un appauvrissement des terres de plus
en plus fort alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire mais il faut toujours mettre des
ans mais le rameur jack ne parle pas que
l'europe il parle du monde et le modèle
qu'on peut développer en europe on peut
le développer dans le monde entier
d'ailleurs c'est qu'on peut l'imposer
aux pays du monde à berne afrique par
exemple quand vous voyez les pays et
notamment la f aol deal faut développer
l'agro écologie le même musique parle de
trois ans pour retourner là pour
inverser le réchauffement climatique je
pensais qu'en trois ans peut l'imposer
au monde entier mais coûteux en afrique
il ya beaucoup de petites exploitations
agricoles donc là c'est pas le pire le
pire c'est en europe ou alors on a
choisi un modèle hyper intensifs ou plus
vous avez des hectares plus ou toucher
des subventions de la pac ça vous voyez
que les écologistes ont voulu vraiment
balancer ce système on n'y est pas
arrivé mais il va falloir qu'on y arrive
oui je trouve que on est vraiment une
phase de changement de modèle sont se
dit on se donne les moyens ça va être
dur c'est dur de changer
on préfère continuer sauf que là on
augmente les inégalités on appauvrit la
terre voyez on a plus de pratiquement
d'oiseaux ont rien n'a pratiquement plus
d'insectes les pollinisateurs
disparaissent donc il nous amène au mur
c'est le sens de la mort oui l
agriculture intensive et alors
n'importe quel prétexte maintenant ils
nous disent ah non mais ça c'est écolo
c'est c'est du rêve c'est de l'utopie
non c'est le développement de la vie
très bien merci beaucoup michèle rivasi
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes eurodéputés et membre du
groupe des verts alliance libre
européenne
zone europe chez nos voisins et chez nos
voisins ça se passe comment c'est notre
rubrique en partenariat avec h j
l'institut des hautes études de
journalisme de montpellier cette semaine
la pma avec ismaël à diallo en france la
pma procréation médicalement assistée en
fin de chaque année plus de 400000
embryons autorisé par la loi biotique
datant du 6 août 2004 et après une
révision le 7 juillet 2011 trois
techniques sont aujourd'hui légalisés en
france notamment la fécondation in vitro
consistant à un transfert d'embryons de
la gpa la gestation pour autrui ou cette
fois-ci l'embryon est directement
intérêts intégré dans l'utérus de la
femme plus communément sa technique est
appelé d'ailleurs la mère porteuse ou
encore la procréation qui est celle ci
regroupe l'entièreté des procréation
artificielle
utilisant des techniques médicales
la limitation était instaurée uniquement
aux couples hétérosexuels ayant des
dangers à procréer naturellement ou une
infertilité sévère ce n'est que depuis
juillet 2020 voté à 60 voix contre 37
que la pma étaient autorisés à tous les
couples lesbiens et ou aux femmes seules
sous certaines conditions
une décision une décision pardon par
tardive par rapport aux autres pays de
l'union européenne effectivement la
france et seulement la 11e sur les 27 à
accepter cette loi le premier ayant été
les pays-bas suivie de l'espagne mais le
combat n'est pas encore fini car la
femme du couple est ce bien n'ayant pas
porté l'enfant se verra obligée
d'adopter le nouveau né alors que cela
n'est pas le cas pour les couples dits
hétérosexuels
soon europe voyage
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
voyager dans l'acier de cette semaine le
terroir est à l'honneur le chef david
shellman du restaurant le coq de
bougival une dévoile la recette de son
tartare de canard poêlé au foie gras et
bien bonjour bienvenue au restaurant le
coq de bougival dans le 78 à bougival je
m'appelle david shellman je suis le chef
de l'établissement et ce jour je voulais
vous proposer une recette donc une
recette emblématique de de la maison et
que j'ai toujours fait c'est le carter
de canard poêlé au foie gras des petites
pommes de terre sautées avec des
champignons des petits oignons on a un
joli mélange de foie gras de canard et
de pommes sautées avec un petit jus de
viande alors vous allez avoir besoin
comme pour un tartare traditionnel un
petit peu d'oignons un petit peu de
câpres il cornichons la mayonnaise du
ketchup de la ciboulette un petit peu de
tabasco sauce anglaise et puis le le
canard qu'on va c'est comme un tartare
de boeuf en fait alors là on a le magret
qu'on va dégraisser
partiellement
donc lampre par la viande
ensuite donc vous allez acheter le
canard vous allez retrouver comme ceux
ci et là on va commencer
assaisonner avec un petit peu de câpres
comme ça un petit peu de temps michon on
continue avec les petits ingrédients du
tartare comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure
c'est comme un tartare de boeuf des
petites herbes fraîches
je mets une cuillère de ketchup un petit
peu de mayonnaise
c'est ce qui va permettre de lier la
viande un petit peu donc un petit peu de
tabasco aussi pour bien le relever la
sauce anglaise
un petit peu de poids
un petit peu de fleur de sel et on va
pouvoir commencer à mélanger
mélange bien
quand je vous disais c'est vraiment
comme un
commentateur de boeuf
on va lui donner une petite forme
pour qu'il soit pour kiel pour qu'ils
soient le plus régulier possible je le
tass un petit peu comme ça pour lui
donner la forme du cercle je vais
également coupé une belle escalope de
foie gras une petite dame voilà la chute
a eu une belle escalopes c'est ce qui va
venir terminer la cuisson du tartare et
on va l'assaisonner un petit peu
un petit pot de fleur de sel de ce côté
là on va dans l'ordre commencée la
cuisson des petites pommes de terre
comme ça on pourra venir poser le
tartare de canard dessus
un petit peu de matières grasses
pour commencer
je vais rajouter un petit pot de beurre
pour obtenir une jolie couleur
on va s'étonner petit peu
rajoutez quelques champignons frais
et on continue de les faire sauter
c'est vraiment une recette qui est
facile à faire à la maison
pendant ce temps là je vais commencer à
mettre à chauffer ma deuxième poil pour
tous qu'il va me permettre de cuir le
tartare de canard avec le foie gras
comme ça ça fait pas trop attendre nos
invités
je vais rajouter un petit peu
donnions un petit peu de ses dettes
alors tout ça ça donne de la couleur ça
donne du goût et on va commencer
à baisser un petit peu le feu
on va laisser faire tout ça après avoir
assaisonner avec un petit peu de poivre
ç'a vraiment à la maison
c'est facile
et vous ferez plaisir à tout le monde au
dernier moment je vais rajouter un petit
peu de persil toujours
pour donner du goût
et les rendre
toute jolie
voyez ça commence à être pas mal
alors maintenant on va s'attaquer au
tartare de canard on va décaler ses
pommes de terre qu'on va laisser finir
de cuire gentiment et on va procéder à
l' on va démarrer la cuisson du du
tartare et du foie gras maintenant
on pose
le tartare alors le but du jeu sur cette
recette c'est d'essayer de le servir
rosé comme un magret un peu à kurt vous
voulez donc là on va baisser un petit
peu le feu
et on va venir travailler la matière
grasse de fondre un petit peu vampire va
aider à cuire notre notre canard
là il ya une petite coloration qui se
fait et à côté on a notre escalope de
foie gras au site va doré
et qui va nourrir la viande de canard
on essaie de le garder rose est un peu
dans l'esprit d'un magret
et après on va venir mettre notre foie
gras dessus il faut pas trop qu'il faut
qu'ils restent
pas trop
pas trop cuite surtout c'est important
voilà ont l'âge le décale pour qu'ils
finissent tout doucement pour qu'ils
montent bien en température à coeur
voilà maintenant qu'on accumule tartare
qu'on a qu'une petite pomme nos petites
pommes de terre sautées on va pouvoir
passer au dressage moi je suis j'ai
triché un peu
je vous met un joli jeu devient au fond
de l'assiette comme ça
je vais venir mettre mes petites pommes
de terre avec les champignons ils ont
terminé cuir
voyez elles ont du goût est long de la
couleur
pareil je la forme du cercle pour que
mes pommes de terre reste bien en place
voilà
je viens récupérer le canard que je
viens posée
par dessus
on n'a plus qu'à retirer le cercle
moi j'aime bien un petit peu si vous
l'êtes une petite pluches de cerfeuil
voilà le tartare de canard poêlé au foie
gras
avec les petites pommes de terre sautées
forestière avec des champignons un joli
giang et le tour est joué
soon europe
les superstitions en europe avec kevin
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine
aux augures le monde antique était très
superstitieux les grecs les rôles à
décrypter dans le ciel
un signe qui pouvait être fatale
c'était une science
ceux qui savaient lire ces signes et
airbus peas et il donnait là le nom
d'augurer de bonne augure ou de mauvaise
augure tout signe qu'ils pouvaient être
interprétés comme ça
d'une manière générale tous qui
survenaient de la gauche qui se disait
sinistre à nous on a gardé en vieux
français semestre la gauche était
négatif donc les investisse regarder le
ciel tu les matins et à les regarder ce
qu'ils veulent est si c'était des
oiseaux noirs qui arrivait de la gauche
c'est un présage extrêmement signifie
qu'il fallait abandonner le projet qu'on
avait en revanche si les oiseaux
survenait de la droite le
chant c'était plutôt lent
même si les oiseaux étaient sont moins
d'ailleurs
on donne comme exemple célèbre
césar qui n'a pas écouté son art us
peace lui avait déconseillé
par le survol des oiseaux qui l'avait vu
le matin où il est allé au sénat se
faire assassiner par toute brouille ils
n'auraient pas dû y aller c'était bien
entendu tous les oiseaux qui avait volé
du côté gauche il serait pas allé zone
europe c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui
merci aux équipes techniques du
parlement européen de strasbourg vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission podcast
audio et vidéo sur notre site et notre
application radio sensations et aussi
sur tv soixante dix huit rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
très bonne soirée
zone europe / sensations
son europe
[Musique]